-"Billy on the Street,"
had never, until this year --
And congratulations.
I'm so happy.
It's so well-deserved.
You guys got nominated
for an Emmy.
-For best variety
sketch series, yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
Thank you.
-Yes. And you used Donald Trump
in your Emmy campaign.
-We did. This was
a huge billboard in L.A.
It said, "You nominated
Donald Trump for an Emmy,
but you won't nominate
'Billy on the Street'?
Be on the right side
of history."
-There you go.
-Yes.
And we got nominated!
-You got nominated.
-But hold on.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
I need to say something
about this.
Because I'm very happy
to be nominated.
It's very nice.
-It's an honor to be nominated.
-An honor to be nominated.
But since -- I swear, since
the second I got nominated,
everyone is saying to me,
"Well, you know you're gonna
lose to 'Saturday Night Live.'"
Right?
-Yeah.
-Because they're in
the same category.
Right now, on the one hand,
I'm honest about these things.
I know all about award shows.
It's probably true, you know?
"SNL" is great.
I grew up with "SNL."
You know, I watched it as a kid.
On the other hand...
what is another award gonna do
for "Saturday Night Live"?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's true.
-I mean,
let's talk about this honestly.
-Great.
Let's get it out there.
-Okay. Now, I know I'm supposed
to just be nice and gracious
and happy to be nominated,
but that is simply not the case.
-No.
-Okay?
-And not the Billy I know.
-No.
It wouldn't be true to myself
if I didn't say these things.
-Yeah.
-Why does Lorne Michaels
need another award?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Listen to --
I know he produces
this show, too.
-Yeah.
-But he's -- he's -- he's --
[ Laughter ]
Oh, we're just getting started,
by the way.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So, he's a TV legend, right?
-Yes.
-He has millions of dollars.
-Countless awards.
-Tons.
-And a lifelong friendship
with Paul Simon.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you know --
-And Paul McCartney.
That's right.
You know what I have?
-What?
-Student loans.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I still -- I do!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Still?
-I have student loans!
I'm not on fancy NBC.
I was on truTV!
I don't even need the award.
I need to melt down the gold
and take it to a pawn shop.
[ Laughter ]
I have health insurance, Seth.
And "Saturday Night Live" --
why does "Saturday Night Li--"
I mean, I get it.
It's an institution.
It's a staple.
-Yeah.
-Okay. But that's like giving an
Emmy award to pizza, you know?
-Yeah.
-That's like saying, "And the
Emmy goes to a piece of pizza."
[ Laughter ]
It's like,
we all know pizza's great.
It's been around forever.
I don't think
it needs to be congratulated.
-Yeah.
-Seth.
And then people say --
Then people say,
"Well, 'Saturday Night Live,'
it had a great year."
Well, it's about time!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
I mean, they've had --
They've had 45 years to prepare!
[ Laughter ]
I guess sometimes it takes four
decades to "work out the kinks"!
[ Laughter ]
And then -- then people say,
"Well, 'SNL,'
it has Kate McKinnon."
Well, can you imagine how much
harder it is not to have her?
-Yeah, that's true.
-I'm at a severe disadvantage.
[ Laughter ]
And it's not only "SNL"
in the category.
Tracey Ullman, another legend
is in the category.
-Yeah, probably
has won that before.
-Many times in the '90s, right?
She basically established
that category.
But I am here tonight
to officially begin
my smear campaign
against Tracey Ullman.
-Good.
This is healthy.
-Yes.
People don't know this.
Tracey Ullman was in ISIS.
-No!
-Yes.
That's right.
That's right!
Tracey Ullman is a terrorist!
-As herself
or one of her characters?
-I don't know!
She was wearing that hood.
Who knows what voices
she was doing under there.
It was her and Marty Short,
Catherine O'Hara.
-Oh, my God.
-ISIS started out
as a sketch-comedy group.
-Okay, gotcha.
-People don't know that.
It's very hush-hush.
Right?
But it's true.
So I want you
to join with me now
in a chant about Tracey Ullman.
Are you ready?
Lock her up!
-Oh, no!
-Lock her up!
Lock her up!
That's right.
Thank you.
-All right.
"Billy on the Street."
This was an incredible moment
of campaigning.
-Let me say one more thing,
Seth.
Do you know when
"Saturday Night Live" started,
women did not have the right
to vote in this country?
-That's true.
-It's true!
Why are we gonna
give an award to that?
-Yeah.
Wow, this is --
This is quite convincing.
Now, I should note that --
-I'm realizing now, maybe
that isn't doing me any favors,
what I just said.
-But again, I also
have a show in that category,
"Documentary Now!"
-Yeah, but that's not gonna win.
-Okay.
-I mean, come on.
[ Laughter ]
Billy Eichner, everybody!